from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out the biggest
differences between uk and u.s
mcdonald's
this is what a small drink looks like in
the uk this
is a u.s small this is what a medium
drink looks like this
is a us medium this is a lodge
oh and this
is a u.s large
so with our mcnuggets in the uk
the default adult sizes on the menu
are a box of six
a box of nine or a share box of 20.
nuggets you can get a box of four
or you can get a six piece or
ten
twenty for sharing or
ah
40.
and according to the three mcdonald's in
the area they don't have 20 or 40 boxes
they just do many increments of 10. but
this is on the menu
in the uk we've got three sizes of fries
these are small fries in the paper bag
here is the small fry these are our
medium fries and the iconic cotton here
is the medium fry and then these are our
large fries and here
is the large fry
so we can find an exact weight
measurement for this rise online so what
we're gonna do is wear them ourselves
[Music]
just out of curiosity gonna bring our
trusty friend the scales back and we're
gonna weigh the big mac and see if there
is any difference in size i'm not sure
there will be but let's find out
hang on
so while mcdonald's fries might look and
taste pretty similar in the uk and the
us in the uk we only have three
ingredients which is oil salt and
potatoes
the mcdonald's french fries in america
have way more ingredients these fries
are made from potatoes obviously a
vegetable oil which has canola oil corn
oil soybean oil hydrogenated
hydrogenated
genitated
thank you hydrogenated soybean oil
natural beef flavor dextrose sodium acid
phosphate phosphathy
pyrophosphate pyrophosphate
sodium acid pyrophosphate which is used
to maintain the color uh are they that
much of a different color than the ones
in the uk is it worth it can we get a
side by side comparison are that much
more bright yellow we need to put sodium
acid pyrophosphate or whatever it's
called in it
salts and i should mention that a
natural beef flavor contains hydrolyzed
wheat and hydrolyzed milk as a starting
ingredient and of course i have no idea
what that means so the biggest calorie
difference in a big mac actually comes
from the source in the u.s they've got
about 40 more calories than we do in the
uk we're not sure if this is because
there's more source or because of the
ingredients list in the uk it's just a
little bit more simple
[Music]
our sauce is made of soybean oil sweet
relish which is made of diced pickles
sugar high fructose corn syrup distilled
vinegar salt corn syrup all right two
types of corn syrup xanthan gum
calcium chloride spice extractives water
man i've heard of that egg yolks
distilled vinegar spices onion powder
salt propylene glycol alginate garlic
powder vegetable protein which has
hydrolyzed corn soy and wheat sugar
calama color turmeric extractives of
paprika and of course soy
lachapen
leachate
lycopene
i don't know which one it is
so if you are trying to eat healthily at
mcdonald's it might actually be the
drinks that you have to look out for
that's nothing guys
our chocolate shake 840 calories
that's as many calories as two
cheeseburgers and one hamburger
so what does that all mean if you were
to walk into a uk mcdonald's and order
yourself a large big mac meal with a
milkshake it would be around 1400
calories and if you were to get the
large big mac meal with the chocolate
shake in america the total here is 1800
1870 calories so that's 1870 calories
the daily calorie allowance for an
american dude is 2500 okay so you have
630 left
one mcnugget is 55 calories right so you
could also have 11 more nuggets and uh
there you go that's all you need for the
day
here's everything you can only get at a
uk mcdonald's
so here we've got the veggie deluxe
burger which is a veggie burger that's
served with some mayo and some lettuce
here we've got a chicken legend
which is a chicken burger again served
with my own lettuce chicken legend i
don't even know what that is not going
to catch on that can stay in the uk
we have a range of wraps that you can
get in the uk we have a wrap of the day
here we've got the fighter crisp which
is some chicken along with some veg and
some spicy fatty sauce here we've got
some veggie dippers these were actually
introduced as part of veganuary in 2020
in the uk but they've stuck on the menu
so these are vegan society approved and
they're sort of like a fried bean patty
sort of thing
like pick a more unappetizing thing to
get at mcdonald's
actually differs and then finally we've
got some mozzarella dippers which are
just kind of mozzarella sticks really
well
sucks to be in the uk because everything
you see right here is usa only baby
usa only
so i'm going to talk about the coffee
drinks real fast here in the u.s we have
all the same coffee drinks they do in
the uk but every coffee drink has an
iced
version and also a caramel
and or french vanilla and or mocha
version depending on what you're getting
so we in the u.s of course have more
variety
shamrock shake the shamrock shake is
like it's like vanilla and mint shake
strawberry sundae
this has recently been discontinued in
the uk sorry guys still got in the u.s
my favorite as a kid
caramel sundae fruit and yogurt parfait
maybe it's healthy i have no idea
probably not
those were the cold items i want to get
out of the way as they slowly melt under
these lights got a lot more to go
through
harry
bear with me here buddy
buttermilk crispy chicken sandwich yo i
think this was introduced when the
chicken sandwich was really heating up
when chick-fil-as are taking over let's
see what's under the hood
look at that
look at this
quarter panel with cheese deluxe this is
your fancy quarter part of cheese this
is uh
for a sunday dinner when you have
company over ah so much
sausage breakfast burrito even after
it's for a while it's like still like
glowing
yellow
[Laughter]
now these are the buttermilk
crispy chicken tenders these smell
amazing i don't want to bite into so bad
i just take a big bite i want to talk
about sauces real quick okay i'm at
mcdonald's and i go give me one of
everything i've heard from the i've
heard from harry and the team over the
uk that some of these they don't have
including sweet and sour honey mustard
what else don't you guys have i don't
think you guys have ranch either or
buffalo i gotta say though the sauces
are everything we've got a couple of
sauces that are kind of unique to the uk
as well we've got a sweet curry dipping
sauce
and then we've also got a salsa dip as
well which i didn't know existed until
today
oh yes donut sticks
these
donut sticks also come with a chocolate
dipping sauce another thing i'm certain
they don't have in the uk
yeah
breakfast is served
look at this oh yeah who's ready to
start the day
it's mcgriddle talk
[Applause]
[Music]
so for those of you in the uk who don't
know what a mcgriddle is
the united states mcdonald's had this
genius idea what if we took breakfast
sandwiches replaced the buns and made
them pancakes and somehow injected some
sort of syrup flavor into the pancakes
and the mcgriddle was born and i have to
say they're fantastic this one right
here the bacon egg and cheese mcgriddle
this is the
sausage
[Music]
this is the sausage egg and cheese
mcgriddle
american food engineering at its finest
look at that
in the uk you guys call biscuits cookies
here no so in the uk
biscuits are cookies what we call
cookies in the u.s
uh biscuits are what we call
uh
i don't know what else you can call them
like
you bake them and they're from the south
and they're dry and i don't know what
they are much like the mcgriddles
we have a version of every breakfast
sandwich that instead of the regular bun
bread it's biscuits not the cookie
biscuits like you guys have um
these biscuits joe you were so close on
the whole cookie biscuit thing what you
guys call biscuits we would actually
kind of call scones or scones depending
on where you're from and the thought of
putting breakfast food in between them
is kind of weird they're usually
reserved for cream and jam for an
afternoon tea
last
and
in my opinion
least
is this thing
the
southwest
grilled chicken
salad
but can i can i eat now
yeah yeah
i don't care how many calories it's just
really good
mm-hmm
you